peppa pig  has gone gay everything else is gay so  peppa pig has gone gay too i don't i've  never watched peppa pig i guess i could  have started to watch it with my  children soon but i now have no  intention of doing that critics have  apparently taken issue with peppa pig  because it glorifies the family on the  left they want to destroy the family  because the family is a great impediment  to their cultural and political  revolutions  so in 2019 they started a petition that  demanded that the series creators add a  same-sex couple not just a same-sex  couple by the way a same-sex couple  with  adopted or surrogate children i don't  know how they got children but  with children you know they want to  create this kind of  mimicry this this  this imitation of a family with all the  kind of sexual revolution stuff built in  the petition has garnered over 23 000  signatures  and now peppa pig has given in